A teacher is helping one of his students
who was stuck trying to complete a
reading assignment.
The same is write a 500 word story
about her hometown and she can't write a
single word. Her town seem
so small, so insignificant.
How could she ever find something
interesting enough to write about?
The teacher thinks about this and
he decides to change the assignment.
Okay.
He says,
your new assignment is to write about
the opera house outside the classroom.
In fact,
start with the upper lefthand brick.
The student is so confused how is she
ever going to write about a brick?
But she didn't really have any
other choice but to get started,
once she sat down to write this exercise
destroyed her writer's block and she
seemed to have endless creativity.
She came to class the next
day with 20 inspired pages.
When Josh was first starting
his journey in chess,
the first instructor he had did things
a little bit different than most.
He took nearly all the pieces off the
board and had him practice with just a
king and upon versus a king.
A little counter intuitive as most people
will start from the beginning and work
their way through the whole game.
But in the beginning there's too much
to focus on and most people will become
lost by the sheer number
of options they have.
What Josh has teacher did instead
was having focused on less this way.
His mind wasn't hindered by countless
options and he was able to internalize
high level chest principles.
We basically have two approaches we
can take to learning the first and most
common in our add society to try and cram
more and more information into our head
to try to recite more facts
and learn more technique.
So we appear to have more knowledge,
but this is a very
surface layer knowledge.
A good example of this would be to click
on Facebook right now is go through the
500 different gurus,
philosophers and stoics,
who all seem to have the
perfect philosophy on how
you should live your life.
Probably based on the last
Oprah episode they saw.
The second approach is to narrow your
focus to one or two things to do less,
but to do it incredibly well.
Yeah,
to focus on depth over breadth through
Josh's approach to learning with just a
few pieces on the board.
It gave is my room to think and completely
internalized how each piece moods.
He would then move on
to a king and a night,
then a king in a rook until he deeply
internalized every single piece on the
board. Now when you actually
dove back into the complex,
middle and opening game positions,
the chaos seems slowed down.
He could see the
intricacies of each piece.
He learned more by focusing on less,
what do you call,
discovering the macro by diving into
the micro and does his knowledge grew,
he was able to chunk new
information faster and faster.
Chunking the ability to take
a large amount of information
and group it together
under a certain principle or pattern where
can now be accessed as a single piece
of information.
Yeah.
This creates something called a
carved neural pathway in the brain.
Imagine it is having to cut your way
through a dense jungle with nothing but a
machete.
Yeah.
In the beginning, this will take
an incredible amount of time.
You will have to monotonicity
Plod your way through,
but once you carved out a path,
anything that fits on that path can
get through almost instantaneously.
As you learn,
you will be able to discover organizing
principles that allow you to access new
information with increasing ease.
A man wants to walk across the land,
but the earth is covered in thorns.
He's two options.
One is to try and pave a road to
try and tame nature into compliance.
The other is to make sandals.
Making Sandals represents
creating an internal solution.
It represents a mind that is
working in this soft softsoap.
It does not require a submissive
world to be successful.
Instead of does a state of mind that
relies on preparation and resilience and
resilience is a trait that can be built
up over time by planning setbacks,
distractions,
and adversity into your practice.
There are certain people you run into
who you just know. No matter what.
We'll always find an excuse
to not get something done.
They can't do it because they're sick.
They can't do it because their
girlfriend broke up with them.
Do you think Michael Jordan is going to
skip practice because he's not feeling
good?
Do you think Michael Phelps is not going
to go slam because his girlfriend broke
up with him? No. If anything, they
are able to take distractions,
pain and setback as fuel to work harder.
It actually makes them
perform at a higher level.
Nothing is going to stop them
from completing their work.
This is because they have cultivated a
mind that lives and breathes in the soft
zone. To become a master, you have to
train and perfect your art no matter what.
If you have a mind that is operating
in the hard zone, you were saying,
I have no control over my fate and I need
the world to cooperate in order for me
to get my work done.
On the other hand,
if your mind is operating
in the soft zone,
you will either completely ignore
external pressure or actually use it to
enhance your creativity.
Cultivating a practice in the soft zone,
we'll give you an internal locust of
control, not just in learning but in life.
You can create a proactive, like when
that you build from the inside out,
you're not reactive to whatever
stimulus you happen to be exposed to.
You're not going to become a lawyer
because mommy and daddy always wanted it.
Even though deep down you
always wanted to be an artist.
You were going to live a life
that is true to yourself.
True Learning and growth comes when we
act in the outer reaches of our ability.
You're like a hermit crab that is
constantly outgrowing it. Shell,
the only way the crab will grow bigger
is by abandoning the safety and comfort
of his former shell. Now, he has to take
a soft, mushy body out into the world.
At times you might outgrow certain
comforts, certain practice routines,
certain teachers you are now like a soft,
mushy buddy crab.
At times like this,
you have to go out and test yourself.
Otherwise you become like an
anorexic crab that refuses to grow,
so he doesn't have to leave his show.